Well,
your income shit.
Now I've got to find another job after I
talked about blackface. Yeah. God Damn.
Megan Keller. Megan. Oh my gosh.
Over and she was loving it where she was
at Fox she worked at before where she
could say all kinds of crazy shit. They
don't care about black face at Fox. Yeah.
Why can't you give her a raise, Matt?
One. Yeah, you should be able to.
You should be able to
have a bone in your nose.
And then she goes over to, was
it NBC? Why would you go there?
You know that's not for you,
dude. Apparently they did
not like her from the jump.
The inside word is that
she was not a nice person.
They did not like her to be around.
They're looking for reasons to
get rid of her. That's the word.
That's the inside work.
But don't you hate that when you hear
that someone's not nice and they're making
millions of dollars, that's true, but,
and she's not nice.
How about someone is annoying to her?
Maybe she's not a nice cause.
You're annoying.
She's out there trying to
educate people about blackface.
Motherfuckers tried to show her
game and she came to people.
Listen, it's just color.
What's the big deal?
Santa Claus isn't black too.
Yeah, it was awesome. Yeah.
That was a part of the extended
Megan Kelly bit that I edit down.
Oh, I had a guy in the office who
was working with her. I was like,
have you worked at the bank and
Kelly after like about a year?
You're not doing any work all day long.
All you're thinking of is someone
gets a fucker. Why can't it be me?
Like if you're in the cubicle right
there and you run into you time,
you time you trips to the coffee machine
when you see her walking. Not yet.
Not yet. Megan, just want to let you know.
Santa Claus definitely white. Like
you'd say, things like you more
horrible. That's a lot of guys,
a lot of guys working in offices.
You're not supposed to hit
on your coworkers. Now,
isn't that considered a microaggression
or toxic masculinity or some of those
things, but then what if you
love her, which she loves you.
If it works out,
what if her husband is a jerk?
You'll take care of her
kids. Oh my God. No Way.
I can't even imagine. I mean,
I've been with Tommy for so long.
Oh my God,
this is what I think.
I think when people work together,
if you work together for eight hours
a day, you're spending as much,
if not more time with that person that
you work with every day that you do with
your spouse and you are only home like,
look,
if you're home in the morning,
how much do you get to see your,
your wife or your husband?
Fucking an hour,
two hours in the morning and most you get
up, you run into the shower, excuse me,
brush teeth when they eat breakfast and
see progress. We got going on today, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Then
we're playing basketball with
Mike, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And then for eight
hours, eight hours of the day,
you're with some other people.
You don't spend eight hours flat with
anybody other than the people that you
work with. You get home. It's what?
Seven 38 o'clock you watch TV,
you have dinner.
By the time it's 10
you're asleep. That's three hours. You
got like three hours with that person.
They were eight hours with this guy was
trying to fuck them. I know. You're right.
You're right. Because I worked
at a company I had, this guy was,
he ended up marrying his assistant. Ooh
Shit. But he did that thing where like,
this is my work life.
That's what they start by doing.
They break you down slowly and
they're like, this is my work wife.
This is my work husband. Ha. It's a
joke. It's a joke. It's a joke. Now
what happened after that was come.
Oh, that was, oh, sorry. Yeah,
because Tommy always like, I held in a
fart that whole time we were doing it.
Are you proud of me? That's
his cabin. It's real romantic,
but they're married now actually,
but that's how he courted her and
she was way out of his league.
She was a hot 20 something gorgeous
girl. Married. Now they have,
you know how many kids, I don't remember,
but what happened? How did he hit her?
He w he broke her, so she was dating
some guy that wouldn't call her.
It was kind of like dipping out
on her and stuff. So He'd be like,
I'm here for you. Let's go out after
work. Let's go get some drinks. Right.
It's that and your friend. I'm the guy
that's going to show up for you every day.
Dumped that guy. I'm here. I'm here.
Even though he's just saying he's the
work husband who's saying I can be a real
husband. Uh, yeah, yes.
Yeah. And to her you up.
Yeah. That's what she wanted though. She
wanted to be wiped up. Wiped up. Yeah.
A lot of girls want to be wiped up. Yeah.
That's great. Yeah. What would you work?
That's the best.
I'm an idiot.
Why don't I go on the road and we want
to make a living career has while your
craft.
Yeah. Right. How would,
it was really sad when guys wife up. I
know a guy that's wifed up, you mean?
Oh, when the woman takes care of
the man got all the money. We only,
and that's awesome.
Like to stay home and he looks miserable
because he doesn't have any say he
doesn't have any income. I got all
the money. So who has the money?
Has the power in the relationship.
She didn't even earn the money
came from the family. Fantastic.
They're involved too. They're always
around. I know that's not good.
And he's a weak, weak, weak. So
that's a dark place for a man to be.
No sovereignty,
no control of your existence.
No real financial decision making ability
because you don't bring it in he money.
She's scaring me right now, feeling guys.
And they settled for that. Oh, you know,
let's you gelled this
looking more things frame.
He was no really work.
Yeah, we wash it. I work.
You know Willman makes all the money her,
her.
You think that relationship
can't ever work that dynamic.
Does it make sense to you? Why
would it work? It's like, yeah,
I mean maybe the alligator
and the cat can be friends.
Course. That shit ain't gonna
work. It's just not going to work.
It will work if it's not a
real man. And, and you know,
and the woman likes that scenario.
And if the guy's just like this
spineless little cheese head,
I think you're, and it's
totally on PC. Yeah.
And I think you're right because I think
he's got to be kind of a Beta male.
He's the guy who likes his balls
busted a little bit. Maybe. Yeah,
maybe he likes his nuts squished. He
was just scared. He's just scared. Yeah.
You know, look, it's,
if you're in a relationship with someone
and that someone is a woman and she
makes far more money than you and you
just decided to let her pay all the bills,
that is a squirrely proposition.
It may work.
It's entirely possible.
You might find the perfect woman and the
perfect man where their personalities
gel together. Neither one of
them gives a fuck about money.
And yet the guy still a man
and the woman is still a woman.
It's just that she makes
all the money and you know,
he kind of like does the dishes and
takes it in the ass. She pegs them,
she puts out a strap on,
she pisses his face.
And that's how he gets money
for food or beets or try it out.
Try it out. The quality. She does
whatever she wants. She smacks him.
He can't leave. It's like you think
that's what's going on? Yeah, I think so.
They have no power,
eh?
Well, let's see. What about Oprah and
Stedman? Stedman makes a living too,
like he did.
What does Steadman
stem is like one of those pirate beers
that you glue on at a party and everybody
knows it's not a real beer is a good beer.
I didn't even know what, it never
really occurred to me. I don't really,
I don't know.
I just couldn't be together forever.
But could you picture opie and Pussy?
Yes,
1000% but I think Gail Gail for
her isn't so much a lover as a mom.
I don't even know Gail is. That's her
best friend. Guilty. I'm not aware.
My the loop. Come on
now. Gail. Serve her BFF.
That's the one they think that
she's friends. No, I don't know.
I don't know. I mean, I don't possible,
that's not the case. Yeah, it's possible,
but they know. I don't want to assume.
Oh, she looks good there. Over a skinny.
I was skinny. Oprah for
all of them. Stickers.
That's one thing. Steadman is just
steady and then go. Nowhere does,
it doesn't even make a good living though.
It doesn't have a job
thing. I think Steadman does have stuff
going. Yeah. I think he's like, oh,
I want to say he's a lawyer or
something like that is I Google him.
It said American educator, so I
don't know. Well, here's the thing,
teacher or something. Wouldn't you say
that when someone, regardless of, uh,
male, female has nothing else in
life going, you know what I'm saying?
When they have no drive,
no focus, no, no goal.
Yeah.
That in and of itself is a bad thing.
It's a bad thing regardless of being
the man gender. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
People with no hobbies. Like you
don't, you don't enjoy doing anything.
Like even if it's just like reading, you
don't, you don't like doing it. Yeah,
I do too. But you don't let
you to do anything. You don't
want you to do anything.
Like you don't do anything. What
do you do? You Watch TV and eat.
It's a lot of people beacons though.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Beliefs. They tell jokes.
That's true. And when they're not telling
jokes, they watch TV and eat. Yeah.
Yeah. I used to do that a lot. We're a
fucking weird group of people, you know?
I mean if you really stop and
think about how odd our group is,
I'll have a little of that. I don't want
you to drink alone. There you go. Plus,
I probably should have a little alcohol
after all the alcohol. I'd yes, yes.
Written 11 self help books,
Steadman bottom.
How to marry rich hose cope when your
wife is way more successful. How to get,
get some rich policy. I know, you know,
as feminist as I am because I
obviously I'm down for the cause.
What is the cause? Well,
a quality, right? Uh,
to the choice to have choice.
To do what the fuck you want.
Do you want to stay home? Raise
your kids to home, raise your kids.
You want to go out and drive.
Well, fucking job. I agree
with that as well. Yeah.
Maybe I'm a feminist sound. No it,
yeah, I think you are actually a word.
I think you are. What'd you get
the ice this whole fucking time.
It's been right here. God dammit
it. It's a high class operation.
Did I put my fingers in there? Get in
there. Okay. I trust you and I know,
oh gosh,
but here's the deal.
You know my mother was a European
lady and as a female comic,
I'm an Alpha in the streets,
but I'm kind of a Beta in the sheets.
You know what I'm saying?
I like to take care of my husband.
I think that's why Tommy and I work
out because I like to, you know,
I bake fucking Rice Krispie treats.
I have shit food in the house.
I'm kind of a traditional wife.
Well,
you're powerful,
but you're also still a woman and
there's nothing wrong with that.
If that's how you like to be.
The idea that there's something wrong
with that because you're supposed to be
even with him.
So you supposed to be treating each other,
not like your traditional male versus
female role. Even if that's what you like,
that becomes a problem because it's like
a pressure problem that women will put
on other women to behave in a different
way because they don't want to reinforce
traditional gender roles.
Oh, right. Yeah, sure, sure. Even if
that were role feels right to you.
You want to do like it. I like it.
I like taking care of my kids. Yeah,
but there's some dirty cons out there.
They'll tell you that's bad
or dirty cause angry bitches. Yes,
that's true. No, you're right.
I've had some people say stuff to
me about it and I'm like, well,
it makes me happy and if that's all that
matters and it's my choice to do that
stuff. I'm not saying I do it every night.
100% yeah. Whatever makes you happy.
As long as you know hurting anybody,
that's all that matters and the idea that
there's something wrong with you doing
that, like this is fucking
stupid. Yeah. It really is.
It's just stupid or silly. Or
are you about, you had that guy.
A lot of that though of what was a
lot of that stupid madness out there.
People telling people the way
they shouldn't, shouldn't live.
You know you don't have much time.
I mean,
you and I are halfway done, basically
almost dead when you think about it,
when you turn 40 you were like, oh,
this is it dude. And like, yeah,
how much time you got left?
Hopefully another 30 years of good living.
I'm saying before you really
start to break down, shit
starts falling apart. Yeah.
Wheels start coming off and people
are worried about dumb shit.
Like whether or not this woman
works or she should have a career.
She should do this. She
should. She's happy.
She likes eating cheese and getting
her toes done. Leave her alone. Yeah.
Yeah. That's funny. I think
that is a middle age revelation
though. You go like, oh,
there's only so much time left.
I don't give a fuck about all this.
Like I'm going to do me Bro.
The guy that I know that stuck
that's the wife makes all the money.
You could see it in his face,
though.
I could just see this a quiet anxiety.
It's like a lion at the zoo where
they're kind of broken or like,
you know that they're a hunter inside,
but you take that instinct away and they
get the meat thrown at them and they're
just like, sadly, kind of just
eat the meat off the tray.
It's like a Vegan cat right.